mr vice president great to see you
great to see you too sean okay so you're
in my neighborhood you're doing a
fundraiser for uh new york gubernatorial
uh hopefully
zeldan um
welcome to this part of uh america where
you want to get away as fast as you can
because taxes are insane in new york
state
glad you're here it's great to be here
sean thanks for having me you know um
these are troubling times
let's start with our own government is
saying they anticipate
that a russian full-on attack of ukraine
is imminent
within any hour
it could happen certainly they think
within the next 48 hours your reaction
to that
well i just must tell you that
to see the way the biden administration
has handled uh
ukraine is a testament to a historic
truth
that weakness arouses evil
i mean this is an administration from
very early on
approved the nordstream 2 pipeline
literally virtually
a gift to russia
reopen negotiations over the iran
nuclear deal
and then the disastrous withdrawal from
afghanistan i think has created
the conditions that emboldened our
adversaries around the world including
putin and russia
to do exactly what they're doing today
but but i must tell you the lack of a
strong american response
which would not include military troops
but it would include you know redoubling
our efforts to make sure that ukraine
has the ability to defend itself
by itself continuing to ship arms at
record pace
to have punitive sanctions before the
fact
of a russian invasion which as we know
has already begun
i i think is is a testament to the fact
that uh that the world has judged the
leadership
of the biden administration and found it
wanting
and now more than ever
we need to send a clear
message of american strength
we say that
okay
now
the the
trump pence administration did not grant
the waiver for the pipeline now joe
biden did grant that waiver they have
since today announced sanctions against
nordstrom 2.
okay a reversal back to your policy
but i think there's another huge factor
in all of this and that is i think one
of the greatest accomplishments of the
trump pence administration was for the
first time in 75 years america was
energy independent and you left office
giving america leaving america as a net
exporter of energy how big a factor is
that in all of this
well it was no accident
that that russia
did not attempt to redraw
territorial lines in europe by force
under our administration
why why not why didn't they do it
well in 2008 right when the bush
administration was in office they went
into georgia in 2014 they took crimea
when joe biden was vice president
of the united states
under our administration we came in and
the first thing we did was rebuild our
military we restored the arsenal
democracy we made a commitment
to defend our nation and to stand with
our allies around the world we sent a
deafening message of american strength
and peace comes through strength but it
wasn't just that
it was when russia's ally syria used
chemical weapons on innocent civilians
president trump ordered 58 cruise
missiles in when the last administration
had allowed them to cross that so-called
red line and did nothing and then where
we took down isis and abu bakr
al-baghdadi we took out qasim salamani
what what russia saw what china saw
under the trump pence administration was
a was uh was american strength a
commitment to defend our nation and a
willingness to use force
to to prosecute our interests around the
world
and i just must tell you that again that
combination of
of
capitulation to iran reopening the iran
nuclear deal
capitulation on the nordstream
ii agreement we had put the sanctions in
place
because president trump said early on
we're going to call on our nato allies
to to live up to their commitments to
our common defense and we are going to
oppose efforts for germany and europe to
become dependent on russia for more
natural gas
we put those sanctions into place and
and one step after another
it was that communication of american
strength that i think held russia at bay
but it but it's been the signals of
weakness and most especially
the disastrous withdrawal from
afghanistan that i think has emboldened
our adversaries it's emboldened putin
and the only response is american
strength no
i would imagine president xi is watching
as well he has spoken at length about
quote reunification his term with taiwan
that's not reunification
and he's been very aggressive
taking over
taiwan air space flying his fighter jets
over them he's cracked down in hong kong
covert 19 the uyghur minorities
there's been no significant response if
you were to tell joe biden tonight what
are these what would be the position of
strength at this moment with vladimir
putin
on the verge of invading
ukraine how does he stop it at this late
hour it seems that the ship may have
sailed well first let's be clear my view
is with russian military in the
so-called separatist regions
they've already invaded ukraine
agree the way to stop them and more
importantly
to get them to withdraw i think is
threefold number one we need to continue
to arm ukraine
they're not a nato ally we don't have a
mutual defense obligation but we ought
to be shipping more and more armaments
anti-tank missiles remember under the
under the obama biden administration
they sent blankets and
military meals
when our administration took office we
we sent armaments to ukraine to be able
to defend themselves
we ought to be doing that redoubling
those efforts
secondly this initial round of sanctions
weak as it is
is not enough to stop putin's ambitions
to redraw
territorial lines in europe by force
what we ought to do is we ought to
sanction every financial institution in
russia until
the russian military fully withdraws
from ukraine remember we're our economy
is roughly 15 times larger
than russia's economy we're the most
powerful economy in the history of the
world and to impose sanctions on
financial institutions to cut them out
of the monetary system where the
american dollar is used
is literally to cut them out of commerce
around the world and so
i believe
we ought to be putting strong economic
sanctions we ought to we ought to be uh
arming ukraine in a very real sense and
and lastly we ought to be
moving resources
through nato to our nato allies in the
region because my concern
as putin moves across the landscape in
ukraine with ambitions that i think go
well beyond these so-called
separatist areas uh that it likely won't
stop there
you think they want the whole country
well look in
at the baltic states in play because
in our first in our first year in office
russia was amassing troops
along the border of eastern europe and
what was to be the largest military
exercise
since the end of the cold war
so our administration sent me to estonia
and i met with the leaders of estonia
and latvia and lithuania just to fly the
flag with our nato allies and make sure
russia knew that we intend to keep our
commitments to our common defense a few
months later i traveled to montenegro
where russian agents had attempted to
assassinate a head of state and had
involved themselves in trying to
manipulate montenegro as they were
moving toward uh joining nato so you
know
the reality is that they're
we ought to be arming ukraine making
sure that they can defend themselves we
ought to be bringing economic pressure
uh on on russia through the strength of
our economy and sanctions
um but beyond all of that we also ought
to be shoring up
uh our commitment to provide for the
common defense to
all of our nato allies in and around the
region you have any doubt taiwan is next
and that china
will will go after their territorial
sean sean i was just on the korean
peninsula
and
heard that just in in recent weeks
china had sent the second largest aerial
armada across the taiwan straits than
ever before and the largest was just a
few months earlier the reality is china
is continuing
to act in a menacing and a threatening
way toward taiwan
north korea actually fired seven
missiles
during the month of january alone so
again i say i say what i said in the
beginning weakness arouses evil
and whether it be north korea back to
firing missiles whether it be the
military provocations of china and the
taiwan straits or the south china sea
whether it
whether it be the
russian military now moving across the
border moving
uh into ukraine um we're learning once
again the lesson of history
that
that the free world is secure when
america is strong
and the world understands that we are
willing to use that strength to defend
our interests around the world
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else